When is a language A language?
What constitutes a language?
And I, sort of, am thinking about
this question as I'm heading off on my
trip to Denmark, Sweden, and Poland.
Uh, and I've been practicing
my Danish and my Polish, my
Swedish is already fairly good.
And so then I think to myself,
well, Danish and Swedish and
Norwegian are very, very close.
They're kind of mutually comprehensible.
The Danes have an easier
time understanding the
Swedes than the Norwegians.
The Swedes have a harder time
understanding the Danes, but essentially
the vocabulary is very, very similar.
The structure is very, very
similar, and yet they are
recognized as separate languages.
Now I move on to Polish, which I've been
essentially only listening to and reading,
and I don't know how I'm gonna do there.
I will certainly do some
videos when I'm in Poland.
You know, in Denmark, I might do
some videos and you'll see that
I'll still be speaking Swedish,
but they'll understand me.
I, I've, I don't think I'll be pronouncing
Danish, but when I'm in Poland, I'm in
a totally different language system.
So if I'm gonna try to say anything,
I'm gonna have to say it in Polish.
Now I know other Slavic languages,
but they're sufficiently different
and, and no one suggests that Polish
is actually Czech or Ukrainian or.
It's a separate language.
There is no issue there whatsoever, but
these languages influence each other.
So if you say take, uh, Czeck and
Slovak, now those are considered
separate languages, but they're
so similar that Czecks and Slovaks
have absolutely no difficulty
understanding, understanding each other.
So why is that two separate languages?
Question.
All right.
Uh, a similar situation, uh, occurs in,
in the Balkans where, okay, Slovenian is
somewhat of an outlier, but, uh, Bosnian,
Serbian, Croatian are so similar that
probably, you know, differences within
those countries can be as great as the
differences between those languages.
And yet there are some people who say,
well, I speak, you know, I'm a Serbian.
I don't speak Croatian.
Uh, but a majority of people there,
from what I've heard, agree that
it's essentially one language.
Although Serbian does, can use
Cyrillic alphabet, but also does
use the Latin alphabet at times.
I don't fully understand why
they use the one or the other.
Um, also in the Balkans you
have Macedonian and Bulgarian
that are very similar.
Again, I don't speak either of those
languages, so, so you start to see
where sort of the political situation
tends to determine whether a a, a form
of a language is considered a language.
In other words, is there a country there?
Uh, but that's not necessarily clear
either because, you know, in Canada we
have the people in Quebec and in New
Brunswick and elsewhere in Canada who
speak French, but we have two languages.
So it's a bilingual country.
The the situation of Ukrainian,
there are people in Russia who don't
want to admit that the Ukrainian
language exists when in fact...
I don't know the full story of
the evolution of Ukrainian and,
and the Belarusian language.
I think they were essentially
the Ruthenian language, and that
was one form of say, Eastern
Slavic languages and Russian.
It was a sort of a different form and
the, uh, lexical distance, in other
words, the vocabulary uh, as between,
you know, Russian and Ukrainian is
actually more distant than say the
relationship between Ukrainian and Polish.
Getting back to my Polish situation,
and of course there are all kinds of
historical reasons why that's the case.
If we look at, at Asia, for example,
there's 90 million speakers of
Cantonese, yet Cantonese, is it
a language or is it a dialect?
The interesting thing is that
most Cantonese speakers consider
themselves to be Chinese and are not
that interested in having a separate
language status for Cantonese.
To the best of my knowledge,
some do, but a majority don't.
The ones that I have met, they don't
make a big deal out of, of the fact
that Cantonese is a separate language.
They're happy to speak Cantonese.
They have Cantonese radio, but they're
Chinese and they speak Chinese.
Um, you know, in Taiwan you have this
Min Nan language, which is also spoken
in the southern part of Fujian Province.
That seems to be more recognized as a
separate language, although again, I
can't, I'm not an expert, so maybe it's
just considered a dialect of, of Chinese.
You often hear Chinese languages,
what I would consider to be languages,
are considered dialects because
that's how the people who speak those
languages seem to look upon them.
From what I can tell, um, I'm not
knowledgeable about differences between
Indonesian and, and, and Malaysian,
for example, or, you know, Thai and,
and Laotian or any of those situations.
I'm not at all familiar with them.
Uh, so at what point is it a language?
At what point is it a dialect?
If you go back to Europe, of course,
uh, there used to be a lot more
regional languages in France, in
Italy, in Germany, for example.
And then gradually there was this
sort of centralizing trend in the
19th century in particular as part
of the sort of national awakening.
So the Germans gotta have one language,
the French have gotta have one language,
and they and the Italians, and they ended
up essentially discouraging and in some
cases depressing or even forbidding people
from speaking these regional languages.
In Spain, the regional languages
seem to have survived better.
So Catalan and uh, and Gallego, Galician,
uh, is still there as a regional
language within the romance group.
Of course, Basque  is a another
regional language, and even within
the Catalan language, some people in
the Balearic Islands or Valencia say
that their language is different.
It's a different language.
Or is it Catalan?
Again, I don't know.
I'm not in those discussions.
But there is a sort of, sort
of subjective nature as to what
we consider to be a language.
Um, you know, I I, I have no familiarity
with Nahuatl, for example, in Mexico,
but I understand that there are some
interesting situations with Nahuatl
or Guaraní in Paraguay that they're
most closely related, sort of Native
North or Native American language
may not be the one that's nearby, but
sometimes there's one from further away.
But they are certainly
recognized as languages.
We have a case of Esperanto.
There is no Esperanto country, but
people who speak Esperanto feel very
strongly that it's an important language.
So maybe the decision on whether something
is a, a language or not, or a dialect
that should depend on what the speakers
of that language think and believe.
I think if, if, uh, the speaker of a
certain language says, I speak language
X, it's a language, it's not a dialect.
I think we have to accept that.
Uh, and if that is, then, if that gains
general acceptance, then not only is
the speaker of that language saying
it's not a dialect, it's a language.
But if we accept it, then it gains
general acceptance and then that then
becomes a language and not a dialect,
but it's, it's a difficult situation.
You know, people might refer to, say
the, uh, Haitian, uh, what do they
call it, Creole, uh, sometimes the
term patois is used to describe a sort
of, you know, uh, a hybrid language.
But look at the languages of Europe
that, um, you know, emanated from,
from Latin, uh, in France and
in, in, uh, Spain and so forth.
The Iberian Peninsula, they must have
been some form of patois, even English,
which is a, a hodgepodge mixture of,
I guess there's some Celtic words in
there I don't know, but predominantly
Germanic words and, and words not so
much from the Romans, it turns out, but
more from the Norman French and out of
that evolution, patois, whatever you
want to call it uh, came the language
that is known today as English.
So the fact that a language is a
mixture of other languages or that
is an sort of process of evolution,
none of that is, is disqualifying.
None of that is strange.
It's all a part of how languages
evolve and, uh, ultimately the decision
on whether a patois or a Creole
or a dialect is a language or not
becomes and remains quite subjective.
So I look forward to lots of
comment from people who know a lot
more about this subject than I do.
Thank you for listening.